whether you need a snowstorm a huge gust
of wind or a fake rain shower this man's
got you covered some TV shows and movies
film scenes in extreme weather
to make the story feel more realistic
but there's one big problem with that
approach you can never count on the
weather to work for you
Jeremy Chernykh is a designer at JM
special-effects in Brooklyn
you can't schedule the entire crew
around waiting for snow so you often
have to make it yourself
Jeremy's company creates practical
special effects for a variety of live
shows music videos and other productions
all the Disney Broadway shows Aladdin
frozen he made it rain on Shawn Mendes
at the 2018 MTV VMAs J&M also rents out
equipment for TV shows like Gotham and
Elementary basically any conditions you
can imagine he can whip up but the trick
to creating fake weather is that it just
needs to look real in the camera frame
don't need all the weather in the world
to to know it's raining in a shot this
big you just need rain in the background
or rain on top so what exactly does it
take to create the illusion of weather
on camera or on stage
[Music]
there are a lot of different ways that
rain is done and it depends on whether
your interior or exterior outside you
can get a permit to hook up a hose to a
fire hydrant or a water truck you can
split that water out to a variety of
locations and usually law hi big towers
go up that can spray water from
unbelievably high indoors you need a
self-contained system attached to a
water supply right above me is a rain
bar so we have rain that is pouring down
in sort of a five-inch channel so if
you're looking dead at it it's a it
looks pretty three-dimensional because
you have rain you know here and here and
plus we can add a level of sort of mist
into that that will just give it an even
larger depth of fields and you can have
rows and rows and rows of then the
systems in place to keep that rain from
never ever dripping unless you wanted it
to rain is actually more complex than
the moments when it's actually raining
[Music]
it's mostly fairly low-tech there are a
number of different products that are
used to replicate snowflakes you can get
pretty large paper flakes that you that
are squares and they fall in a very
beautiful and specific way you can get
shredded paper that falls sort of
organically you can get shredded plastic
which has a different feel to it and the
way that you deliver that is through
blowers that are blowing it far overhead
and along distance they also have
special soap based products that won't
stain clothes or make the ground
slippery essentially it's like tiny bits
of foam and that is a machine that is
pushing that soap through a kind of
filter that makes it into snowflakes
environmentally there's all sorts of
stuff that ends up in the air to fill a
picture in terms of haze fog smoke these
effects are usually produced with a fog
machine the most commonly used interior
fog is glycol based which is in a type
of alcohol sometimes you want the fog to
fill the screen and other times you want
low-lying fog which requires a few
special tricks and is most often done
now using liquid co2 or liquid nitrogen
to chill the glycol fog to a very cold
level and that coldness is what keeps it
low to the ground the thing that's funny
about wind to me is that you don't see
wind unless it's either moving clothing
or hair or if it has some fog or some
level of fog in it JMM has fans of all
sizes we have incredibly quiet fans
designed specifically for a live
television with any of these weather
effects you want to be extra careful to
protect camera equipment and the actors
there's a shield there's plastic bagging
there's sometimes tents there's also a
risk of flooding indoors often scenery
is going to be built in designed with
water catch underneath so it will be
raining on what looks like the floor but
it's designed to collect water
well these weather systems may not be
exactly like the real thing
they get the job done you don't have to
do a huge amount of post work if your
special effects are right and they look
right and they're telling your story and
the realistic stuff is is you can tell
it's real
[Music]